alright Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
is on his way to Turkey this morning he
will want to talk about the fight
against Isis but the Turks want to
discuss this man a controversial Turkish
religious scholar named Fethullah Gulen
Turkish president air tawan accuses
Gulen of being behind a bloody coup
attempt in that country last year Glenn
who lives in the United States denies he
was involved the Turkish government is
lobbying the Trump administration to
extradite Gulen back to Turkey now let's
go back to Margaret Brennan at the White
House she has some surprising
revelations about his followers in the
United States Margaret good morning good
morning well the Turkish government
calls Fethullah Gulen a terrorist
while his followers say he has merely
become a scapegoat for turkey's
power-hungry leader but here in the u.s.
he faces a new challenge CBS News has
learned that the FBI is investigating
whether his followers skimmed money from
US schools and charities to fund the
movement back in Turkey a violent coup
attempt shook Turkey last July hundreds
were killed as road military tanks
rolled into the streets of Istanbul
but the man the Turkish government
blames for inciting it has lived in this
Pennsylvania compound for 17 years his
name is Vitaly Gulen and his followers
run publicly-funded science and math
focused charter schools in the United
States by our count they've opened 136
charter schools in 28 states operating
on more than two billion taxpayer
dollars since 2010 but former teachers
at those schools have told CBS News
there is a scheme by gülen's followers
in the u.s. to take advantage of the
American charter school system and fund
Gulen's movement air Sun [ __ ] core was
once a follower for to Allah Gulen
he worked as a math teacher at schools
founded by Gulen supporters in New York
and Texas but he says school officials
made a special demand of the Turkish
teachers who worked there a kickback
from their taxpayer-funded salary
teacher need for seem to give some of
that money back to them yes were you
writing checks they were asking cash I
paid some of them in check how much
money do you think you paid to the
movement I mean more than 20,000 in
total maybe Mustafa and Manette was an
IT administrator at a Gulen inspired
charter school in Ohio how much money do
you think you gave I was being run 40
percent of my salary 40 percent of your
salary yes based on information provided
by eminent federal investigators believe
former officials at his Ohio school
illegally paid themselves about five
million dollars in federal contracts and
then sent some of those US tax dollars
to a bank in Turkey linked to gülen's
followers the school says it is
cooperating with the probe they're a
threat to our relationship with Turkey
and thus to the stability of the Middle
East former US ambassador to Turkey
James Jeffery told us gülen's followers
are a powerful force in Turkey with
public good works but more private
political aims we need to investigate
this movement again first and foremost
for what it is attempted to do in Turkey
secondly what it is trying to do here in
the United States and what laws it may
be breaking in the process of doing so
fethullah gulen repeatedly declined to
speak with us but we spoke with his
closest advisor Alba's Londo ins if
there was a proven charge that somebody
illegally channeled money from public
funds into some private purposes he will
be first to contaminate the Turkish
teacher said that they were then forced
to hand over part of their salary back
to the movement mm-hmm yeah forced
donations is absolutely unethical it is
disgusting
I would I would be first to condemn
something like that the charter schools
that employed Turkish teachers concore
and M Annette strongly deny any official
links to Fethullah gülen himself but we
found nearly all gülen schools have ties
to a network of nonprofits many of which
lead back to Gulen or his top associates
and court records related to gülen's
immigration to the u.s. show that his
lawyer said he had quote overseen the
establishment of a conglomeration of
schools including in the United States
what do you think they're really trying
to do they try to gain more power and
power and they want to make more money
and then after that they use the money
to gain more power now Aaron Concours
former employers dismissed his
allegations and accused him without
providing evidence of being an agent
working for the Turkish government a
charge he denies gale but Concord did
tell us he spoken to lawyers working for
the Turkish government right there's
certainly more to hear about that story
thank you very much Margaret